[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
you want to read
why
have you uh
had an experience with that 12 years at
youtube i've seen some pretty awful sh
you had any experience with that
you mean personally
yeah
yeah
i have
it's never good
my boss at youtube was an alcoholic
mean [ __ ] drunk
she used to come in hammered looking the
whale on somebody so i'd provoke
hoping she wouldn't go after the smaller
channels
interesting nights when she just
finished watching fox
yeah they used to just outright
demonetize our videos
till they realize that violating public
single-party consent laws could cause
more damage
and there was this one time this [ __ ]
complained that we filmed them without
permission at a public town hall while
he's advocating and pumping kids full of
puberty blockers
youtube execs gave us a choice to blur
every face in the whole [ __ ] video or
said we could just
skip the time and have it outright
removed
said shoes well i'd have to go with just
removing it there vanna we went with
blurring all the faces
why
because [ __ ] them that's why and your
account received a heart strike anyway
yeah
so what is it crowder's got some kind of
rebellion complex or something some kind
of a
general problem with authority is that
why i have to put a half asian lawyer on
retainer full time
i didn't know you had
yeah well i did
you want to talk about it no
hey crowder
i don't know a lot
but you see this
all this [ __ ]
the demonetization the heart strikes the
video removals the policies
it's not your fault
yeah i know that
look at me son
it's not your fault
i know
no
it's not your fault
i know no
no you don't
it's not your fault
it's not your fault
it's not your fault
it's not your fault
it's not your fault for me
not me not you don't it's not your phone
it's not your fault
[Music]
it's not your fault
[Music]
it's not your fault
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
strangers
that's an old uh intro
a classic we'd have to update it it's a
little bit your fault it's a little bit
it's a little bit your fault there's a
crowder rule now back then you were just
some screwed up kid who didn't know
anything now it's all your fault yes
your fault it's your fault
used to wake up the dog when she'd
fallen asleep so
uh
look glad to be with you today uh we
have a really big show a lot to get to
just let you know we'll be doing a show
today tomorrow and wednesday boom long
form interview with megan kelly
exclusively
and the dan lemon teen jews you oh so
sorry off the top of the show lemonade
lemonade yes no that's right no not
least no more of a lemon drop
so samir yes transmitter i will say uh
smearing a lemon
i know it's a tough day i know it's been
a rough weekend and uh our our hearts
really go out obviously to everyone
affected there in in waukesha i hope i'm
pronouncing that correctly wisconsin um
it's it's uh i'm hoping that we don't
see a whole lot more of this and i hope
that you do not mistake levity here
because that's our job for yeah you know
with not taking this seriously but it is
our job to inform and to continue making
you laugh hopefully and uh you know what
uh we're not gonna pull these way out
and do an snl or something and just
decide to do the clapter so uh prepare
for some wildly immature dick jokes oh
what and we will talk about waukesha
there's some developments there yeah
take a guess
before we go on uh by the way this show
is live monday through thursday this
week through wednesday just so you know
because with the written house stuff
there have been channels being removed
yeah monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern if it's not here on youtube it's
on rumble it's on mug club you know you
guys can uh anywhere you listen to
podcasts spotify apple android i i'm
only letting you know this off the top
so that you don't lose touch with us we
will let you know if we're missing a
show like this thursday because it's
thanksgiving uh or as i like to call it
uh the day that the final people uh won
after everyone else was warring before
that but we ignored that part of history
we settled it down yeah the day the
people one who didn't
bury you up to your head and let the
army ants eat you alive so you know what
thank god for the guys in metal hats and
red beards
g morgan jr here how are you i'm well
how are you sir i'm okay yeah yeah i'm
doing all right i like your shirt thank
you very much yeah i like this shirt too
we have some new shirts available at
photoshop.com if you're looking for
christmas ideas and of course gerald
sells wine because it's an alcoholic
quarter black how are you hey i'm doing
good hey sorry today's show's gonna be a
little rough on you it's okay it's all
right i'm just kind of tired they don't
speak for all of you they don't loot for
all that's true that's true
i didn't get anything out of it no i
know i know you gotta start look
all i'm saying is when you leave this
show somewhere a nordstrom rack should
be missing a suit oh yes he's the one
guy that would get arrested though yeah
i would you'd have to explain it to them
and show a picture of his dad i'm easily
picked up
hey hey look ah catch and release
go on you little fishy let that one go
go on my my little rainbow trout
uh
don't call me that you prefer halibut no
i don't like any aquatic analogy
catfish pescetarian sons of [ __ ] law
enforcement we have uh you hear his
voice dave landau he's going to be at
the honey bone in liberty ohio
this coming this coming week before
thanksgiving wednesday the night before
thanksgiving i'm gonna be there and
there's only a few tickets left my
you're an insensitive [ __ ] i know
that's why it's good it's the night
before biggest bar night of the year it
used to be if your kid spills his milk
what do you do beat him up what do you
mean really like you don't know he
doesn't know how does he not know you're
the alcoholic how does a drunkard not
know
the biggest oh yeah he doesn't i get
drunk on wine not booze that's true
doesn't change anything beer just so
because that's in the bible
well jesus did make wine he did turn
water into wine
he was a walking give him a horn he
wasn't a snob
it was total jesus
no it was duty-free jesus it was
duty-free christ no
no
no no he was also a great source to pick
up some cubans uh
so uh i don't mean cuban cigars i mean
something little wrong apostles i'm sure
no guys
so here look this just passed before we
get to waukesha before i get to walnut
creek wahika what do you say i said
polito oh okay did i it's wakasha right
walking am i pronouncing that right
correctly okay because i'm sure it's not
polito
i was back on the cuban jesus thing oh
okay of course we're moving on oh that's
what we're despite the four glasses of
pinot you had before this show
bye which button
those were big pores yes those were big
pores it was the pinterest glass like
not until i've had my glass of wine
i hate those like bumper
i had my second second cup of coffee
it's like oh so you're a non-functioning
[ __ ] until you have
your stimulants it's one o'clock
somewhere so your husband has sex with a
secretary
i had fruit for dinner liquid fruit
oh you lush i hate you
soccer mom
driving your kids around with your
thermos of wine your kids are looting a
walnut creek nordstrom so uh
last week the house passed we didn't
have much time to talk about it because
we're talking about the written house
trial which
um
1.7 dollar infrastructure bill uh but
the democrats know that americans still
really aren't into it just to be clear
they think that government is
overreached and so people say well they
support individual policies if you ask
if you ask americans if they like free
stuff they'll always say yes of course
but inevitably they get uncomfortable
when they go oh gosh you just keep
printing money and what's the what's the
debt now
1900 trillion
uh
maybe i don't maybe i don't need uh uh
medicare for 30 and up so i can invent a
new number to get what we hit yes
exactly you're going to be like
kajillion yeah
broke math right they'll just be like
the kid in blank check only with their
taxes yes and
a garbage can full of ice cream oh great
how much does that cost when it goes
through the government 1.3 trillion so
1.7 trillion dollars they've decided to
create some propaganda to get americans
on board with
a gross offense to the legacy of
schoolhouse
rocks in the
[Music]
do
house
screw the vice president
he's not even in there
[Music]
all
right you better pass me
oh we didn't make this as a parody no we
did not ask no ours would be way better
oh no that's funded by your tax dollars
oh good so they just named off
everything they've done wrong yes
exactly good yeah immigration healthcare
stuff we're not good at
things you don't like about it i want to
see that old bill come back i'm like hey
wait hold up y'all are full of [ __ ] oh
yeah
i've been hooked on smack since the 70s
yeah and because of your three-strike
policy laws crack put me in the clan
they didn't have pants to fit so they
were raping me all the time
i'm a white bill so the bell was very
high
there's no they're saying there's no do
you mean to say mr bill that there's no
catch and release for white bills no
[Laughter]
that's the worst
i know it's so bad and by the way uh is
my question to you we are going to be
talking about today
hey the media's been saying what if kyle
written house was black yeah i'm sorry
no no no no no no no no no no no sorry
what if cowboy announces black that's
what everyone is saying in the media
just to be clear we'll talk about
waukesha all these things that are
happening but this is a narrative if he
were black i bet you'd think really
differently not only do we have a track
record of thinking the exact same and
actually encouraging law abiding
citizens black white yellow any i mean
red i don't know i don't know what
purple you can't even say it red and
yellow black and white they are precious
in the sight that's that's the key there
is precious in his sight with the jesus
yeah yeah but we'll say it we take we
take murmurs with the yellow we do the
point here is um
don't tell ti
is that uh
i think it's a silly argument and i
think that conservatives need to be
really clear about the fact that uh the
second amendment applies to everyone the
first amendment applies to anyone
property rights apply to everyone and uh
this you know what i think i'm getting
to the point where people talk about
defunding the police um we'll talk about
walnut creek
this is something that cannot be solved
through police reform when you're
talking about the rampant crime and
looting self-defense needs to be
important now let me be very clear this
is never a call to violence you know
very well that i implore people to be
peaceful but you absolutely should not
be sitting ducks whether you're white or
you are black and we'll have some
stories to get to but before that during
the thanksgiving uh turkey pardoning
this brings us to this week in biden
there was a little girl who decided to
um
she she decided to send the flaw wax off
when uh alleged pedophile biden decided
to uh
biden her
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump and you
ain't black
[Music]
that was quick quick no she was like
it's like children have an instant
revulsion
uh former vice president yeah just
really just karate chop the sense of
danger yeah now show me send the former
vice president can i smell you
hashtag hell no not me too
do you want to shower until you're nine
you want to play with my leg hair come
on oh i want to go pardon a bird
i love kids sitting on the left you
wanna you wanna eat this bird with me
we're parting in the turkey
and you're supposed to eat the turkey
what we're not gonna eat well i guess a
ham
i don't know this that'll do
they've hardened one they eat the other
it works yeah i have no idea this is
turkey blm yeah this turkey is it to blm
free
bacon lettuce
man they got more kids what did this
turkey do is it
oh huh
where's a kid i can sniff does it have
info on hunter's laptop
is there a diary is there a dumpster
near a grade school i can throw throw i
gotta need a place to throw them a gun
so um speaking of crime that's been
rampant uh this happened this weekend
and i have a few points that i'd like to
get into here it's not that there was a
looting uh at a walnut creek i believe
nordstrom looting mass mass
mass loading
yeah it's pretty they don't even hide it
it's just looting nordstrom on facebook
event
invite
rsvp half the answers are maybe
attending yeah yeah i don't know maybe
looting it's an open group too it's
weird everyone's 10 minutes late
they didn't even carpool so look let me
show you the clip this is coordinated in
a suburb i guess of the bay area uh at a
nordstrom is it nordstrom's or nordstrom
nordstrom nordstrom okay because people
got to think about that uh
walnut creek here's some here's some
footage of it in case you missed it
happened yesterday we got in 4k
[Music]
we got two masks
at
[Music]
you least for this
well now's the time you get the you get
the [ __ ] you voted for oh yeah enjoy it
like a well-organized operation people
sprinted to waiting cars carrying bags
we even call that a sprint that's a
light job
that's a speed walk people running down
the street i probably saw 50 to 80
people yes and like ski masks crowbars
night like a bunch of weapons
in one dramatic scene a car veered
around a police suv to make a getaway
but another officer stopped him with his
gun drawn three people were arrested all
are charged with robbery one of them is
also charged with three a felon
how hilarious would it be if that guy
just sold just stole the samsonite
luggage and didn't fill it up with stuff
yeah
he might have [ __ ] i just need a
carry-on that's a missed opportunity but
if they were just a flash mob yeah they
were like i don't know we couldn't get
the dancing coordinates down and we just
started robin's well i couldn't
coordinate to thriller
so we just took stuff what a great
commercial for amazon stay home and be
afraid yes
order your stuff from us who cares if
you pay for prime and it shows up nine
days late with no recourse you know did
you see walnut creek also uh this is my
issue here it's similar to with msnbc
when they followed the jury bus
it's not that
50 to 80 people looted
a nordstrom it's
how how little accountability must be
feared that they acted that way what has
led up to that and we know that that's
billions of dollars in damages that's
thousands of arrests and and looting and
arson throughout the years it is
incredible when you think about
just how little concern there is for the
law at this point that's what this is
showing you
look behind you there's the tipping
point also guess what the police showed
up they can't catch them all these guys
weren't even these guys weren't even
trying to hide their license plate
yeah that's just lazy crunch
duct tape your license plate come on
they were so like you know what a couple
of us will get i bet you that they all
stole something under a thousand dollars
so that would be not a c it wouldn't be
considered to get calculators out there
and they said let's they probably have a
few of them who stole significantly more
the high ticket items and said we'll
make sure that we split up and these
people get priority so they can leave
the quickest and won't get caught and
some people are going to say this isn't
looting or rioting this is a organized
crime you can't find a gang large enough
to do this let alone
what you think the crips are going to
load in nordstrom
i wouldn't even do it because when i get
home i bet you nothing would fit right
no no you look good on me what a waste
of day changing room takes me forever to
find stuff
like is there anything else i can try on
yeah oh hi police
that's why old navy knows they're safe
exactly
unless there's an amy look amy schumer
look-alike convention down the corner
they don't need to worry about anyone
looting their stuff oh if you could take
everything from old navy and they'd be
like ah 832.
oh jeez who cares
not quite enough do you even want that
stuff i don't i don't know i really need
an american flag shirt that's rainbowed
to fit king kong bundy i always wanted
my wardrobe
can you imagine being the guy walking
out of the store just having paid for
your product go back in i do believe you
have a sale going on i'd like to make a
return flash sale going on it's not
black friday
because i have no idea here's the other
issue uh okay if you want to defund the
police fine you can shoot looters on
site
they go into your store because keep in
mind employees were assaulted injured
pepper sprayed
you don't know when people come in with
ski masks and crowbars or they come in
with blunt objects some of them uh
allegedly we don't know we don't have
all the reporting were armed but yeah
they didn't think you shoot somebody who
pepper sprays you isn't that
i mean
this is because it's california i'm just
saying look if we don't want if we don't
want to have a culture of police and you
want to defund the police i don't think
that defunding the police or increasing
funding for the police would have nearly
as much of an effect as rioters and
looters knowing that business owners
property owners mothers fathers wives
daughters
have the right to defend themselves and
their stuff because what people say is
well life isn't as important as property
once someone has invaded your property
the chances of them taking your life or
injuring you beyond repair go up
dramatically and i can't know
i can't know that the 50 people who come
in and ski masks with crowbars are just
yeah they're down on their luck they
need to get their essentials at
nordstrom
can you imagine being a clerk we've all
had those jobs you're just a clerk at
nordstrom and you're just like oh this
stays taking forever couldn't possibly
get any worse
and then 80 people run in and pepper
spray you and you're just like why like
crowbar to the head oh oh this is i just
wanted
i don't even have benefits at this job
so guys on a smoke break
dutch hats are over there just leave me
alone that guy also killed someone some
of you can relate right
for cry like seriously we're at this
point do people think we'll be morally
wrong if a shopkeeper there no just
opened fire no i don't i don't and guess
what you wouldn't see it happen again
you wouldn't see it go from you know the
five finger discount a thousand dollars
or less some people get beaten by the
way at these pharmacies people don't
understand that because they try and
stop someone from stealing their
livelihood they get hurt you can read
more stories than you could read in a
lifetime all references are available at
louderwithcrowder.com or in the
description and then they go you know
what let's go with five people and then
10 people and now 50 to 80 people you
stop it along the way if people have the
right to defend their property the
second you put someone in fear for their
life
you forfeit your right to safety and
that includes you forfeit
the guaranteed security of your life
especially if you're going with ski
masks and crowbars yeah that's how you
solve this problem but instead we're
living in the harry callahan world the
commissioner's world where they want to
they will catch and release violent
criminals which we'll get to in waukesha
in a second
and instead they'll condemn you if you
defend yourself as a white supremacist
guarantee you yeah if one of those
shopkeepers who got maced or who got hit
panicked shot someone killed them they
would be vilified just like kyle
rittenhouse did anyone doubt that for a
second you want to play the if cal
written house was black let's play if
one of those shopkeepers shot the person
of the wrong color
yeah yeah by the way i hope san
francisco keeps this policy i hope it
empties the city of all the good people
that live there move somewhere else i
know several arrests i know i hope the
rest of the country looks at it and see
this is what the policy does right go
for it implement it
go ahead well it's not just there we're
letting out violent offenders and
defunding the police doesn't work who
knew
well
i'm glad everybody i just i hope this is
worth it that hillary lost and we've had
to deal with this crap like at what
point does america get to stand up and
be america again because the thing we're
about to get into
is beyond disgraceful and like i'm just
pissed at this point yeah it's enough
like it's just enough like you can
scream white supremacy you can scream
whatever you want it's complete [ __ ]
yeah it's not real i've never met a nazi
in my life right yeah but i've met
plenty of criminals and i've had many
guns pulled on my face yes
it's like they're doing i've been
several times to be fair one well one of
them was a skinhead well well one of
them was me i was in the room it was
dave's no i mean i've been robbed at
gunpoint though several times and it's
be you know i was in the wrong
neighborhoods and whatever you want to
say your fault but it wasn't much you
shouldn't have been wearing that short
skirt well and i was wearing a sign that
said rob me yeah and roller skating it
said rub me but they read it wrong there
was a fold in it
they pulled that velcro wallet and was
like oh all i got is these pictures and
a dollar all right uh let me let me kind
of give you a briefing on to mention the
policy in california that might have led
to this in the bay area i hate that
terms like where the bay bay i hate it
so it's diana bechten what's a war she's
the d.a there and uh she stopped
prosecuting her level drug possession
and shoplifting offenses she stopped
prosecuting uh disturbing the peace she
instructed prosecutors to consider the
needs of looters before charging them
here we have chessa boudin the san
francisco d.a ended cash bail decreased
sentence for prior convictions and gang
affiliations he banned prosecution
stemming from pretextual traffic stops
or statements given by officers with
quote racist behavior i don't know what
that means why be a d.a
yeah you're like
you know my job i don't want to do none
of that yeah yeah that's all you're
doing right yeah great
no
yeah what are you gonna do hey let's not
prosecute people what do you want to do
whatever let's call it a day thing to me
that's so funny stopped prosecuting
quality of life crimes and that includes
things like petty petty theft
quality of life well hold on a second
whose quality of life what does that
mean quality of life yeah
well my quality of life isn't as good as
it would be yeah
if
i had this fidelity soon
[Music]
it's a little better
i mean i was if you're yeah
stealing a loaf of bread and 80 people
robbing a nordstrom is a very different
fairy i think it's aladdin out here like
they want you to think it's oliver twist
yeah
like i'm just pickpocketing for some uh
for some unleavened bread no you're not
no you're not no you're not you're going
into a high-end department store to
steal high-ticket items they have
insurance this is something else people
say right they talk about the businesses
burned to the ground let's use kenosha's
example oh they have insurance okay how
long does it take to rebuild that
business insurance doesn't always cover
usually does not cover the lost earnings
during that period of time you have to
lay off employees they have to go find
work guess what they might go work
somewhere else you have to re-staff not
to mention the neighborhood of kenosha
probably not a bustling metropolis no of
farm to table fare and coffee shops at
this point so no this idea that we burn
it down insurance covers it again you
don't care about the actual victims in
the case of looting a store someone owns
that store
someone owns that car lot someone owns
that restaurant someone owns that gas
station you are harming them you are
removing their livelihood and i know
it's easy to sort of disconnect from it
because of the corporate world man but
you have to understand up until very
very recently
taking away someone's livelihood
people thought wars over that they
fought wars over land just because they
thought they could grow crops better
yeah look at what the native americans
did to each other look at what the
mohawks did look what happened in canada
with the the iroquois and the hurons
this is where they turned to settlers
coming in right they turned to to
english who would protect them in quebec
because they they had the french who
were siding with i believe the iroquois
um
they said look we need some funny
english guys with red beards and hats to
protect us because they would fight over
back then land
access to waterways you were fighting
wars over livelihood so you could
provide yeah and now we act as though
taking away someone else's livelihood or
harming it depending varying degrees i
understand
is not a crime worthy of someone
defending it we need to reset the
culture and people will say it's a call
to violence it's not a call to violence
it's a call to violence to ask people to
write in the streets like black lives
matter in new york it's not a call to
violence to say hey look stop stealing
people's stuff stop stop pistol whipping
people and pepper spraying and
crowbaring employees yeah and damaging
stores and by the way the people in
those stores
take care of didn't it
right one of the things that i saw there
was consider the needs of the rioters
when charging people consider the needs
scroll up no seriously like you brought
up a good point a second ago the writers
their needs are consequences they need
to have consequences for their actions
otherwise they're going to think they
can get away with something that they
can't and they're going to get shot in
the process right you need it now so
that you don't have to learn it the hard
way later can you imagine that like if i
acted up as a kid with a parent like my
dad came to me stephen and this happened
did you light the shed on fire uh i did
what do you think you need uh some
whipped cream
i think it's a wooden spoon son
down the neighbor's house yes uh i'm one
of the voices of the unheard yes yeah
yes can we make a s'mores please yes no
no you don't unders you misunderstand
father uh arson re is my language um oh
i see yes
it's just reparations yeah
by the way the researchers just sent me
this boudin um he was elected to public
office uh and funded by george soros's
political action
oh that's fantastic look at that
wonderful nice good i'm so glad that
very powerful people are crippling
america yeah and no one cares and they
accuse everyone else of being a nazi
whereas he was like sid was in the attic
not a giant out loud yeah i think anne
frank even like that [ __ ] soros yeah
you're like oh this is weird this is not
the language it's not as flowery as the
other chapters i know tried to hide in
his attic
i know he didn't mean to blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah he's the
one that was like she's up there yeah
she's up there i didn't even ask they
just said hi up down he's like up yeah
yeah they're like we were just uh we
were just coming by to offer you this
christmas basket but thanks we'll go
take those jews you're one of the good
ones soros
[Laughter]
bye god soros is one of us yes he plays
by his own rules but he finds those jews
good man he's got a real nose so scenes
like this have been very common in san
francisco under boude here's a more
individual clip you know so you can
relate to it
[Applause]
[Music]
well we know he's not stealing belts
[Laughter]
[Music]
just right out the door shut up i like
the dead dream boutique she owns it's
like all the places you can rob it's
this person who's barely hanging on
you got this in 32 uh no why cause you
racist and [ __ ]
shut up who doesn't think that clip
would have ended better with the blam
blam blam blam blam it'll be way better
yeah i mean and then the pants are 50
off because they're stained yes
what are you doing i'm creating scarcity
so do all these fans fit me
he took literally everything grab the
stack i'm gonna take some of these i'm
gonna take somebody and he was so and
again he was so nonchalant about it
there's no fear of repercussions no
running at all he probably walked
outside saw a cop and said good day sir
in his dave chappelle white guy voice
hello
just just going pants shopping officer
oh we told them you know how it is well
then we told the country to uh act
violently and to constantly cover their
face in fear of a cold yes while
simultaneously defunding the police you
know it's all none of this seems like a
bigger thing no you you meant to say uh
encourage them to act mostly peacefully
and uh stop the spread that's right yes
exactly what you meant to i speak nazi
so i can understand wow well that's
meant to say called the dog whistle yes
it is i say flatten the curve and uh
peacefully rob and i say uh austria look
it up there you go oh yeah they've never
gotten it right a good look man uh so i
just want to make sure i understand this
clearly because they're confused yeah so
they did not pay for the pants they
decriminalized crime
now there's an increase
in crime
and organized lootings
so the the da's uh uh
criminal
yeah yeah yeah okay okay
that's accurate all right
yeah there's other words yes
but that would be more offensive yes it
would be more offensive to use a word
that would denigrate somebody than it is
to steal thousands of dollars worth of
merchandise it is ironic that people who
declare themselves the word police have
so much disdain for the actual police
i feel like they put the joker in charge
of police there it's like ah he's like
the kingpin so this guy is getting
kickbacks ah just don't prosecute any
crime
i've been called silly it hurts he's
getting hit with a crowbar not as much
it's look right that's an ouchie yes
sticks and stones may hurt
my bones but names are nein
but names will always kill me that's the
word you better not ask questions i
believe that's how it goes a little bit
yeah pretty close go back to the sticks
and stones parts if they involve
spraying crowbars were candy and nuts
it'd be christmas every day yeah well it
is at that nordstrom yes
everybody gets something this is one
hell of a white elephant
i you know what i already gotta pick or
steal i just steal all the [ __ ]
ho ho ho talking to you [ __ ]
geez
by the way there's this new there's this
new crowbar to table restaurant have you
power
welcome to oakland [ __ ]
no i'm sorry i didn't know we just saw
that we just saw the looters we should
uh they they uh they sound turkish
turkish
like gobble gobble turkish yes yes like
pardoned yes like pardoned from joe
biden
i'll stop i'm just so angry today that
i'm trying it's okay it's okay for you
i'm going to hide it okay for everyone
to be angry because now we got to get to
the waukesha attack so yesterday you all
know that a a car uh plowed through a
christmas parade in wisconsin oh it
wasn't a gay pride parade so no one will
care right exactly no one will know the
media said an accident
yes an accident yeah you drive it well
we have some more info here on the
suspect today and there was a lot of
misinformation on both sides going out
yesterday i would say 95 confident in
what we've confirmed so i want to make
sure that we have it accurate for you at
least at this point at the point of
broadcasting
uh five killed over 40 injured i'm not
going to show you the video i don't want
to show you the video no there's the
video is very suspicious because he does
swerve to avoid some people then
deliberately hits other people the first
story we were given was
oh it was another event that had taken
place a stabbing
or some kind of violent crime and then
he was fleeing and that was and that was
it that was all we heard well that's
obviously not true this wasn't the route
he would have had to take to flee and he
was proactively seeking out people to
kill if you watch the video which
look take my word for it i don't
encourage you to watch the video it
absolutely is this is just heartbreaking
it i get a pit in my stomach even
thinking about it kids
were
as far as we know could have been killed
but here's the thing but why is that i
don't mean
but why is there a defense to it right
away why would you jump to defending
like look guys he was just fleeing a
stabbing it wasn't on purpose yeah
there's nothing to defend well you
haven't you haven't heard of a good old
knife fight come on makai brian that's
what they that's what they do and by
they i mean the kids yeah the kids it's
all tick tock and uh knife fighting
these days but so what so he stabbed
somebody and was trying to get away and
was driving it he's an influencer yeah i
mean literally we're just crying out
loud what are you doing how about you do
your part and open up uh the door to
your neiman marcus for those in need
yeah well dave you know exactly what
they're doing yeah they're providing
cover
of course at least they're praying and
hoping like oh please god don't let this
be in relation to the written house
versus when is the media gonna start
getting charged for the stuff that
they've caused for the last two years no
no yeah it would be never ever well they
should be because there's a difference
between freedom of speech and inciting
complete crime wait wait wait wait you
say inciting
is bad i thought they knew that yeah
they've done it they want to claim that
we're inciting violence by saying don't
allow yourself to be a victim whereas
they go out and say white supremacy
folks the kyle written house jury shows
you that white people can kill anybody
in america what if he was black we're
going to get to that in a second also we
have an example right here of how the
media treated it very differently so it
just said person actually at the time of
this broadcast or at least when i
started this show cnn
still
doesn't have a description of the
suspect they did not at as of 9 00 30 10
30 eastern sorry a.m on monday
so either they're not doing their job
they're really bad at their job or
they're lying at what point do they
cease to be useful at what point do we
realize that they are not news
organizations 20 years ago yeah you
would think so yeah uh uh when the last
time ted turner wrote out in a steer um
here's the police scanner that reported
the suspect
this happened you would think they'd
have access to it considering that we
did well with that jarrell brooks said
rings for anything
moving afraid i ran that subject and
watched on his id in the car he is
suspended
looks like he's actually at least 199 on
the system
that's where he's identifying software
lighter skin blackmail dreadlocks wraps
no shoes
now i guess what cena would have
preferred the description be uh
[Music]
he's a uh
he's a he's a nordstrom shopper
not so much a
he is a self-philanthropist yes
so this didn't stop leftists and media
right away from jumping on to
white supremacy cal written house
narrative so journalist chris wiggins
who is not from a dickens novel uh
tweeted it's okay the driver in waukesha
was afraid for his life and defending
himself from the unarmed holiday crowd
that's wisconsin law now
actor oh that's awesome to say yeah
actor angela belcamino said the driver
from the incident in waukesha will claim
self-defense it's just the new normal
writer janice hoff have we learned what
color the driver was so right-wing media
can decide if running people over at
christmas parade was terrorism mental
illness or someone acting in perceived
self-defense okay look look do you not
underst we cannot find common ground if
you don't realize the difference between
kyle rittenhouse cleaning up graffiti
providing medical care and then being
chased down by pedophiles woman
girlfriend beaters i can't say wife
beater because they don't know yeah they
don't put a ring on it uh and certainly
criminals only shooting people who
violently attacked him or tried to kill
him and somebody who deliberately plows
through
innocent women and children at a parade
do we honestly want to act as though the
if you act like the only differentiator
is race
you're a racist and this is the prime
look let me put a fine point on this the
biggest problem that we have today the
biggest problem we have with our media
is that it is intensely racist
absolutely yes they are intensely racist
and i mean i do mean anti-white as a
general rule and i'm not someone who
goes around said i'm proud to be what
because i didn't do anything to be white
i'm not proud of my skin color i'm not
not i'm not ashamed of my skin color
it's sort of a neutral it's not a
character point they definitely have a
bias against white people and more
importantly they see everything through
the prism of race if the only difference
you see between a kyle written house and
this is race you're a racist and
everyone in mainstream media this is
this is how they replied with the
exception of fox news in a few places
like that how did they all get it wrong
how does cnn not have it up now at least
15 minutes ago
daryl brooks jr was released just just
to be clear this goes back to the
looting problem on a one thousand bond
two days ago
for domestic abuse and bail jumping he's
also registered sex offender and just in
case you don't you know you won't see
this on cnn and msnbc any of these
places uh believe you're lying eyes and
ears here he is explaining the charges
by the way like the wet bandits
incriminating himself
on video
and then as soon as we fall out all of a
sudden now i'm a pedophile let me
explain that
10 years ago 2006 i caught a case with
my oldest daughter's mama yes my baby
mama she's from oakland i was busting
moves in nevada what does that mean i
mean she said she want to get down so
i'm pimping on it it's a great hat
you know what i'm saying i get cracked
you know what i'm saying i didn't know
the [ __ ] was 16 at the time she gave a
statement to the police and told them
yeah she was hoeing that i was pimping
and uh winner man what a winner
monday motivation i didn't know the
[ __ ] was 16. yeah jesus
guy is that a bad is that a legal
defense i think so she was 15. i don't
know
what am i supposed to do card every
[ __ ]
stop stop acting like this i don't have
time to call the [ __ ] between
smacking and pimping
please i got a job to do i love haters
come on i'm not a penny i'm just a pimp
you know what i say to the haters shut
up i'ma keep on living well your haters
are 14 year old girls you had raped yeah
you say tomato i say it's my job the
family of your victims yeah haters yeah
haters
stop breaking the law
and i by the way has anyone else also
noticed that when people say you know i
mean it's usually because we uh i don't
know
i didn't know the [ __ ] was 16. she said
i was pampering she was hauling you know
what i mean uh i actually have no
reference point whatsoever
yeah like you're gonna go no i totally
get it yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
please explain further i hate it when
they're like i'm 16 after right it's
like like you're gonna respond is that
when someone asks you about that haul
and oat song that you're kind of
familiar with you're like oh yeah yeah i
remember that one but you really don't
like yeah you know she was saying she
was hauling i was pimping you know what
i mean
yes
oh you're 16 girl but it really don't
matter anyway yes you can rely on
getting my money go out there and get my
money you're a [ __ ] girl you're turning
tricks
[Laughter]
i knew qb would get me yeah i got you
yeah you know what i'm saying only good
get pimped young that's what i said
gosh so by the way media hasn't done any
digging now people are wondering if
there's a motivation here because it
seems like a targeted attack uh his
social media is full of pro black lives
matter which i define as a domestic
terrorist group in auntie cal written
house can we at this point determine a
photo of a maga hat that said right
kanye's wire kanye's mouth shut again
all caps i don't know if that's the name
of an album that's too wordy uh facebook
it read religion is white supremacy
i i mean come on for crying they still
don't have it up at cnn look why is this
story being buried look right now
they're talking about it right now let's
bring it up on cnn right now let's see
if they mention the guy
uh within at least two feet i could have
touched the car going by was the guy
white or black he threw his child out of
the way i'm tired of this accident and
joins us now
just a little bit natasha
we go now live in waukesha to the avery
family yeah it does take the seriousness
of it i don't know what happened there
with theresa holdback at the parade
uh and but the police really wouldn't
answer any questions about uh what role
that person played or anything that
person said to them when he was he or
she was taken into custody
moderately asian reporter natasha chen
do you not know if it's a he or she or
is this just your gender-bending
[ __ ] where you don't want to did he
do you did you say he when you when you
spoke with me he's like that's some
[ __ ] i am non-binary what happened
he or she is a girl did everyone just
say this in real time oh yeah this is
the problem is this all creates racism
between everybody this divides the
entire country this is exactly what they
want that's why
now parades are like yeah but who's
going to take their kid to do black
people not want safer parades of course
they do isn't it worse that's the
problem is it's not about black people
it's not about white people it's not
about asian people it's about giving
people who are criminals the the green
light to do whatever they want that's
the problem and then these [ __ ] come
out here and don't tell you sorry for my
language if you got kids but you know
i'm not driving a car at you yeah so
count your count your blessings but
instead of sheep yes but you have
different people coming out and saying
different things so you have these new
sources that basically convince you
they're they're basically turning into a
a hit list here of information
and it doesn't include the guy well at
all not at all you don't have any
information could you imagine
this reporting 15 years ago i know well
it probably did happen we just weren't
able to fact-check it that's the issue
it forces us to forces us to question
every single story that we thought we
knew because they were they were doing
the exact same thing it's just now look
you are able to watch them live and
you're able to watch us they have three
people on cnn right now is it okay by
the way you guys hit the like button if
you want me to go to see i want to see
right now in real time give them a
little bit of time to see if they do the
right thing can we do this i think so
because they've got three people let's
see if a single one of them again we
have his information we know what crimes
he's committed we know when he got out
on bail two days ago and for which
crimes his name is is it i want daryl
brooks jr let's see if anyone says it
what compelled this person to drive
their car at that race
out of people you know gathered to
celebrate the holidays it's just uh
confounding
um but you know we're not gonna get an
answer to that uh right away certainly
you already have it still law
enforcement feels more comfortable it's
unreal details uh we've heard different
reporting this morning that he may have
been well i guess we'll never know what
happened on that mysterious thanksgiving
corroborated that yeah we only we do
have the guy in custody there's a person
of interest do you mean when you reach
through the driver's side window and
pull him out yeah the guy yeah well he's
just calling for that he's not
interesting at all
not the dos equis prick some of the
folks that
he passed at least initially which is
you know not what you typically see when
someone attacks a large crowd with a
vehicle uh unless he's aiming for
specific people they're running defense
on him
again he just defended him he just did
he just defended him well you know we
don't know if one of uh to be fair uh uh
prosciutto uh we don't know if one of
those [ __ ] uh owed him money
so we will wait for more information he
she was 15. yes my my point still stands
[ __ ] could have owed him money she was
ho ho hoeing and he was just pimping
allison
who knows you have got to keep your pimp
and strong back to you also it's my
understanding he was aiming for 16 year
olds yes yes because these are his
primary uh employees
yes do you like no word yet if he's a
401k yes do you like the books behind me
i'm a piece of [ __ ] back to you
avenue after he's been inaugurated the
secret service complete oh yeah that guy
really looks like he's gently driving
yeah yeah
yeah i mean he swerved from the crowd
before he hit the crowd
but i think what what local officials
will be questioning is how did you
report the major access points to that
route they we saw the use of some
barricades that were easily drove
through them because it's a car and
those are made of light wood right
they're not expecting somebody to drive
into no no no the crowd we have ensured
of course with uh you know what we
believed in some people said they've
increased funding here i have no idea if
that's true we have ensured that going
forward of course with our limited
budget that we will block off the
streets with entire wicker swing sets
moving forward yes
[Laughter]
in terms of that too we did see some
changes right after other incidents that
happened where vehicles were used as
weapons there's also you know the fact
that
do you need any more proof that media is
useless and we've already gone through
comedy as useless because they want to
be media and media is useless because
they're they're spineless pieces of
garbage well they're hilarious well if
you guys go back to the trayvon martin
case where not only did the president
come out and say if i had a son he would
look like trayvon martin but i believe
was it nbc or abc who played like an
edited clip and made it a race thing by
saying oh he's black and it was like
they left out the part right there where
they said is he white hispanic black and
he was just responding zimmerman was
just responding to the question and you
know what we can probably bring this up
uh uh uh you mentioned the mexican white
supremacy yeah yeah yeah yeah the
mexican white supremacist maybe the
mission control can uh bring this up i
was doing an interview with russia today
and i was doing it from uh my parents
house at that point on skype and as they
were interviewing me i said like and let
me guess you're probably going to run
that photo of a 14 year old trayvon
martin uh and kind of like and they
didn't have time to change it it was on
as i was saying it oh and i couldn't see
anything so we can run that a little bit
later it's just to give you an idea
there are a lot of people now who claim
they've been on this bandwagon for a
while i've always said there is no
neutral media can you can you guys
comment comment to those who are
watching uh of course in in archive
what what purpose does media surf
honestly what purpose propaganda
especially a 24-hour news cycle look
inciting riots it used to be if you had
the you know news at seven or whatever
time they would have it uh news at 11
whatever it is news at five what however
often they would have i think four times
a day is about what they would have it
three or four they used to recap it so
you know what was going on the whole
idea behind 24-hour news was it could
actually be proactive if there's a chase
going on if there's a manhunt going on
in this scenario they have no interest
none whatsoever how long before the kyle
rittenhouse situation that night did it
come out that he was a white supremacist
or tied to militia right now they have
the police scanner audio yeah they've
caught the guy they have his criminal
record and uh and we don't know if uh
you know he or she or uh z uh in in
there uh you know uh could have been
aggravated in fact because it was not a
gay pride parade and that's uh going to
force us to take a a good long hard look
at ourselves back to you anderson yeah
they have eyewitnesses they have
videotape of all of this they had people
just on saying i was within two feet i
could have reached out and grabbed the
guy yeah you couldn't give a description
like he or she listen hold on it doesn't
matter if this guy was black or white
unless it fits a narrative for them
right if it fits the narrative that's
why we're talking a guy that you have to
be afraid of which is what you're all
being told right now if it's a black guy
they don't want to offend anybody and so
they'll just cover that right up just
like wouldn't it be so important if they
didn't yeah school shooter absolutely
though he's right he's 100 right they
did that same thing with that school
shooting we were here and i remember you
were upset saying it seems like it
happens all the time and we were talking
i was kind of a lot of people said it's
a white person problem it was a black
kid shot three people including a
teacher looked like it was a drug thing
it was there was white people don't even
like themselves
do you think we have a problem with you
seriously we don't even have time i
haven't have time we don't identify with
each other as brothers if i see a guy
getting wrestled to the ground and shot
who's a redneck i'm not like he's one of
mine i'm right [ __ ] good
i didn't like the potty right now
there's no world star country yeah right
why do you want to relate to the lowest
people in your society yeah right
there's no reason to do that you're
better than that don't let this media
convince you that we're the bad guy then
anybody with a different shade of skin
the point is if it's a black guy with
dreadlocks you did the crime say that if
it's a white guy with black hair holding
an ak say that exactly the problem here
is they said initially just like we just
read for you the tweets they said ah i
guarantee you it's a white guy and then
when they found out then it was silence
so the lie is amplified and then the
truth is silent that's the issue too
that you need to understand amplified
lies and silent truths
that's the big issue it's not just the
lies that you hear it is the silent
truth like you're seeing right now
technically it's not a lie for natasha
chen there to say
he or she she didn't know his pronouns
he didn't know the problems yeah but
here's what it feels he just went in
before he he did his uh took his mug
shot and then put on some lipstick and
said i [ __ ] me
if you're a 20 year old black man right
now he wouldn't though he's not 16. well
that's true
if you're a 20 or 20 year old black man
right now and all you do is listen to
cnn and major news outlets you do think
that you are the problem because of your
skin color and not your behavior you do
think that the world is against you and
you hear kyle rittenhouse white
supremacist you hear all of this and it
leads to people tweeting those things oh
well they'll probably claim self-defense
because you know it was probably a white
guy in the car and he was threatened by
the crowd that's what leads to that how
do they not understand that they're
creating future problems well we'll get
to in a little bit we talked about this
before uh there's an example of that
girl in kenosha who was underage sex
trafficked by people like the sterile uh
brooks and uh she killed him burned down
his house
and i said great
make him look like the english patient
for all i care yeah how do you have
empathy for a guy who stabbed people and
then drove into a crowd of people but
you don't have empathy for a guy
defending himself from a pedophile
hitting him with a chain uh white
stop with the dog whistles he had a
scary looking rifle okay yeah and it was
semi-automatic i know yeah yeah which is
so cool which is why was anybody
ar means assault rifle because i read
that on twitter it does natasha chen
said so i heard he played call of duty
yeah
once and are we down here well then he's
serial killer he's absolutely a serial
killer hey did this guy play grand theft
auto oh
what
san andreas
uh oh i don't know i'm not a serial
killer yeah i don't know i have no idea
it's a good game i play tony hawk pro
skater too and i really only broke my
own neck i play bond
i play mario kart yeah that's what i do
by the way we got this chat from zach
french please shout out that waukesha
memorial hospital has put out an urgent
request for blood donations absolutely
and the city of waukesha has also
tweeted out about um a community fund
yeah great i'd give you my blood but you
die instantly you don't wanna you would
burn the
dave's like i brought friends not mine
no no no i don't need getting a call
getting from the red cross going why
would you send us this again
biological warfare dave he looked at it
under a microscope and the microbes were
smiling at me oh wow um all right so
let's it's it's
over it's land how dna
so let me go through before we go to cal
written else what if kyle written house
was black by the way smash that rumble
button if you're on rumble right now
smash that
and of course the same thing if you're
on youtube uh we will be playing they
don't make them like they used to that's
right uh on mug club today yeah before
we get to cal right now what if cal
written house was black let's and i'll
present you some arguments but i think
everyone has heard this at this point
it's such a lazy shallow argument i
think we can make the same argument here
i would hope that he got off yeah wait
yeah he's not black
i don't know what he is he kind of has a
just alba quality to him i only watch
right wing news and they never mentioned
it right yeah he's one of the mixed
community so remember how immediately
after let's first go through the worst
takes of cal written house yeah uh again
where people fear no accountability um
let's go back to the guy who everyone
hated president donald trump remember
how reacted immediately after kyle
defended himself in kenosha
then the actions of vigilantes like kyle
rittenhouse
we're looking at all of it that was an
interesting situation you saw the same
tape as i saw
and
he was trying to get away from them i
guess it looks like and he fell and then
they very violently attacked him
and it was something that we're looking
at right now and it's under
investigation but
i guess he was in very big trouble he
would have been he probably would have
been killed but it's under it's under
investigation i gotta i have to tell you
i am actually surprised at how there was
zero embellishment i would have thought
yeah yeah look to be it look excuse me
looked at me like they were going at him
with a nuclear bomb excuse me okay and
he in fact had nothing but a sling like
david he was swinging it around and then
excuse me no and you could see the
pedophile erection who also okay who had
the nuke he had the nuke and i hate that
he had a nuke but he had a nuke eddie
had an erection when you have an
erection in a nuke and all you have is a
sling i uh look i already have a statue
written out
everything he said was 100 accurate and
he said and we're still investigating it
but it looked like it was a bad
situation seems like they're violently
attacking him he tried to run away i
think you've seen the same tape that i
have of course uh when he said i think
that you've seen the same tape people at
cnn abc nbc cbs young turks said k
the young church even admitted that the
one woman from the young turks even
admitted she got it wrong anna
yeah well i think that's because these
some of those della dollar bills lasted
you right but they had already started
trying to corner him there would you
speak out against the militia members
like kyle written it's like whoa whoa
whoa you didn't have any information yet
like no exactly oh god for a bit of
president gives a you know direct and
honest answer which ends up being
exactly what happened and proven in
court and did not poop his pants what
does he think who did who yeah
he then went to the vatican and shat
himself
we have a bathroom incident
yeah you're right that's takes six hours
for your podium to kick it the last
person to [ __ ] his pants at the white
house before biden was al roker
yeah that's true didn't he sharks yeah
he did he did oh no he did he threw out
his underwear he did he threw out his
underwear at the white house barack
obama can you imagine nothing like
perpetuating the negative fat guy
stereotype what are you a clump
i bet you before he lost the weight he
wouldn't even notice when he started
he'd just get home and be like i must
have done it today
another one of those days oh this ain't
something at all but he was like happy
about it because he's out he's stopping
at the train on the way home out to
yonkers and getting a shoe shine
oh what are the whiff guys sitting next
to me on the subway smells like [ __ ]
yeah can you get this [ __ ] out of my
elroka shoes wait you mean these shoes
were cordovan oh i thought they were
black
diabetes juice
get it out with the jaws of your life
imagine what reason they're talking
about you have the video that you asked
for with you
oh with me and trayvon martin okay all
right let's uh let's if i remember
correctly now keep in mind what i am
just talking into a computer i cannot
see anything it's just skype yeah and
from what i remember i called it without
even being able to see it
but that's not really the argument
people are bringing here just like you
guys decided to show the picture of
trayvon martin i don't know why the
picture is several years old whereas a
zimmerman picture is only his mug shot
this man hasn't seen a trial he's been
committed by the american people
[Applause]
publicly tweeting him
right there in the production you know
someone's going [ __ ]
he should do that with the killer like
as you can see uh here he is in his
donatello pajamas
here's zimmerman as a boy scout yes
all right uh so let's go so donald trump
responded that way on the flip side we
had quinn hillier from the washington
examiner immediately published this
article don't cry for kenosha killer
kyle rittenhouse
nicole hannah jones of the 1619 project
infamously tweeted in this country you
can even kill white people and get away
with it if those white people are
fighting for black lives this is the
legacy of 1619 he carried a gun he could
not legally he could not legally have
illegally crossed state lines and killed
two people but sure y'all believe in law
and order so everything about that tweet
is wrong it's so bad corey bush tweeted
the judge the jury the defendant it's
white supremacy in action this system
isn't built to hold white supremacists
accountable it's why black and brown
folks are brutalized and put in cages
while white supremacist murderers walk
free i'm hurt i'm angry i'm heartbroken
and so this leads into
obviously the horrible takes the
inaccuracy and when you set it up
right you set it up with a lie and you
don't really tell people that that's
just
an inference that you're making
then
it allows you to use it as a springboard
to create a straw man argument right
they're trying to say if kyle were black
would have been arrested would have been
murdered but just so you don't take it
from me
here you go i do still feel very
strongly if he was a different ethnicity
uh
or people group yeah he
he'd be gone it wouldn't be no uh he's a
hero and this that there incorrect he
would have said that he was under age he
was he traveled to a smart idea wearing
a rolling paper shirt a firearm that
didn't belong to him it's not okay for
the judicial system to be blatantly and
obviously stacked against people of
color this is still a show it's not so
fake
for there to be an entirely different
set of rules
for white people there's not
but uh i don't care about kyle
rittenhouse i don't care about that
racist judge she's not and i don't care
about how why is she very dressed like
an animatronic musician
since time began yeah exactly so i got a
chuck e cheese yeah like hey what's that
that's the amber ruffin robot yes
[Laughter]
that was eerie it looks pretty good she
looks like yeah they took her out of
discovery zone and gave her a talk show
she's always like very tight yeah she's
very like and don't you love that first
guy by the way with a yeah wear a
rolling paper shirt why'd you pull me
over officer i don't know because your
eyes are bloodshot you smell like burnt
onions and you have a t-shirt that says
i love weed do you want me to take them
that was jacob jacob
really yeah i didn't know that that was
jacob lake yeah yeah the guy
until they said it you mean i'm sorry
the the the wife the man who hit us the
man who digitally raped his wife and
violated a restraining order right
i'm sorry let's rehab your image with
rolling papers yeah the man who should
know that actions have consequences more
than anyone right now i'm sorry you mean
the multi-millionaire because of white
guilt yeah yeah
yeah because who you know all he had was
a knife
i mean you don't you don't bring a you
don't bring a gun to a knife fight
that's true you lose the right to
self-defense you die yeah some people
that's what
that's what a good person does you take
a knifing i mean if you've got a right
gun you just take a knife all of us take
a knifing by the way i'll talk about
that i was right about kyle written out
says defendant what a useless [ __ ] so
uh you've heard his
inaudible yeah that guy's gotta try it
oh his lawyer his lawyer was awful
remember i said he didn't make a good he
didn't yeah anyway let's go remind me to
go back to it let me write kyle's own
lawyer remember i said his arguments
were richards yeah and
he went on chris cuomo and the stuff
that he said since his this guy should
never have been handling the case kyle
is very fortunate yeah which one the the
crew guys with the puzzle sitting there
talking about you know people should
mind their own business and not carry
guns hard r yeah i'm not going to say it
so
a lot of blue man let me just go through
this real quick a lot of blue check
marks on twitter have had similar
opinions what if cabernet sauce was
black uh uh bubba noose in my garage
wallace said ha let the boy be black and
it would have been life hell he would
have had his life taken before the
[ __ ] trial sad julian castro
remember he ran for office i do you
remember that remember that piece of
[ __ ] yeah he still is he said uh you
know damn well that if kyle runhouse
were black he would have been found
guilty in a heartbeat or shot dead by
cops on the scene nope comedian kamal
you ever performed summer no i've never
met him oh okay you're lucky i i haven't
been asked to not be on a show by him
good
counting your blessings instead of sheep
i've never met him but i do know that he
likes to push propaganda yes so he wrote
if you're a black teenage male here are
some things you can't expect to get away
with number one illegally carrying
illegally getting a gun okay good kyle
didn't do that two claiming you're
protecting property that isn't yours and
you weren't asked to protect that's
incorrect three killing two people with
a gun four fleeing the scene you ate cal
written out he turned himself into the
police he went to the police immediately
they said get off the road he said yeah
but i just shot a guy they said yeah we
all have kid get off the road and then
he went to the police station after that
not the same thing kamau bill now uh
let's be clear about this
not all i want to say once and for all i
want
black people to be able to protect their
neighborhoods their family the exact
same as white people as asian people as
owners of nordstrom or the owner of the
little trinket shop down the street or
the owner of the franchise papa john's
or the local italian restaurant or the
the neighborhood watch i want everyone
to be able to protect
their family what's theirs and we need
to stop this culture of victim and what
do i mean victimizing people who are not
engaged in crime there's no justice in
mowing over people at a parade let's
defend it zero there's no justice in
burning down a walgreens let's defend at
zero there's no justice in in
spray-painting dicks all over a
courthouse
in trying to kill a kid at a right
there's no justice in burning down a
used car lot let's be clear about this
and i want these people
criminals to be afraid
of
law abiding citizens from all the colors
of the rainbow
am i clear about that so let me give you
some examples of black people first off
who either have been treated similarly
or or we would support being treated
similarly it's not just a black or white
thing keep in mind the fort worth
shooter black kid shot three people out
on 75 000 bail let's be really clear
about that also on friday andrew coffey
a black man was cleared of second-degree
felony murder three counts of attempted
first-degree murder the jury found it
was self-defense what happened is he
shot at some deputies during an early
morning raid uh they came what i believe
happened is they poked a hole through a
window he thought it was rifle fire he
shot at them they shot his girlfriend
and they charged him with killing his
girlfriend he was just cleared
good yeah as he should be
yeah
if they didn't do their jobs and
announce who they were then that's the
kind of stuff unfortunately that
happened and it is different from
brianna taylor anyway we'll get into
that another day um let me give you some
examples of other people who have
supported black people who are carrying
guns uh or using force david dorn right
former police officer who was shot dead
and we raised money for him that was an
absolute tragedy crystal kaiser she was
jailed for killing her pimp and burning
down his
his house yeah and now this i believe it
was also kenosha they're trying to
charge and say well she only did it
because uh he uh she wanted to steal his
bmw okay to be clear the authorities had
videotape
of this man sexually assaulting minors
she was pimped by him just like the guy
that he or she who ran over people at
the parade right this this lady uh this
girl krystal kaiser was underage was
being pimped sex trafficked she'd had
enough she killed a man burned down his
house and they're trying to say oh but
she did it to steal his car you know
what
sometimes that's that's the booty of war
yeah you take your plunder i wouldn't
care if she cleaned out his jewelry box
and took his flat screen
he was sex trafficking minors it was on
camera but of course the local
authorities and i'm not sure if the fbi
was involved we don't have all the
details yet they wanted to build a
stronger case even though they knew they
had it on camera him sexually abusing
minors but who cares she wouldn't be in
the mentally right frame of mind as a
minor being sex trafficking right well
gives the crap what she thought the
reason was you know what we do in
hollywood when we want you to hate the
villain even more yeah that matters
no we make them sex traffickers that's
what we do every single time we make
them the lowest form of scum that we can
possibly imagine and this girl was
fighting back would we ever blame
anybody that's being sex trafficked for
killing their assailant no no i wouldn't
blame her for cutting off his nether
regions and shoving it in his mouth and
killing him yeah or letting him enjoy
the taste yeah i would let him live at
that point
yeah let him live for a little bit and
then burn the house alive burn the house
but this is all hypothetical it's
hypothetical i'm saying i don't think
anyone would blame a girl who was being
black girl to be clear
sex trafficked underage i don't even
care if she chose to be a prostitute
does not matter hey
have you noticed a theme here we don't
like pedophiles and child rapists
whereas mark ruffalo was calling joseph
rosenbaum jojo like it's one thing
jojo
what's wrong with you man i don't know
one thing he's honestly the worst the
worst alive oh i'm gonna miss jojo jojo
what do you have in your inbox mark
ruffalo
there's a lot of those actors doing that
i know andrew pascal did the same thing
carrie washington said that his life
matters you're like no it
no it doesn't doesn't it really matter
at all and here's rape children let's be
clear too when people it doesn't mean
that people someone who commits a
mistake someone let's say who wh at one
point commits an argument that's not a
mystery no that's not it
michael people but we need to
differentiate between people who make
mistakes and when you look
at people like this person daryl brooks
i believe this darrell brooks jr is that
his name yeah uh you look at joseph
rosenbaum you look at the man who was
trafficking um
is it crystal kaiser crystal kaiser it's
hard for me to remember these names you
look at all these people you look at the
serial wife beater the guy who stabbed
his ear huber you look at people there's
a certain point where it's no longer a
mistake but people who only exist
to leave harm
to humanity and society in their wake
do not deserve the same treatment and
rights as other people we're not talking
everyone everyone makes mistakes and
some people get some tough breaks too
i think there is a difference between
someone stealing a loaf of bread and
someone who looted a nordstrom who by
the way has a rap sheet a mile long this
is the 19th nordstrom this quarter that
he's looted between wife beatings and
sex trafficking there's a huge
difference between people who make
mistakes people who have committed
crimes and people whose existence has
resulted in nothing
but net pain and damage to the innocent
and with kyle rittenhouse those were the
only people who were harmed that's
relevant and in this case right now
that's what we're dealing with in
waukesha wisconsin and they're still not
telling you about it that is weird to me
it is weird to me when mark ruffalo says
jojo why are you so hell why is cnn so
hell-bent on defending underage sex
traffickers why are they so hell-bent on
venerating child rapists like rosenbaum
at a certain point you do have to ask
yourself a question
you don't defend anyone with this much
zeal i wish i loved anybody as much as
mark ruffalo loves the generic pedophile
[Laughter]
just so tired of this and let me want
you to drink the kool-aid or the taint
juice yes
lemonades we're back
not everyone is anderson in the green
group green room don
so uh i just i agree with uh uh yeah i
know all right we're gonna go we're
gonna go to mugler where we're getting
into less trouble but let me give you
also some examples we'll say whatever
yeah we don't want to get pulled off
here for a disliking pedophile yeah no
you can't do that
no because if they get if they get rid
of us
well then you know it's going to be a
problem because then they're like wow if
we get rid of them we have to get rid of
all our pedophile pornography and
youtube can't do that yeah and you don't
want to make mark ruffalo angry no you
don't want to make him angry he's going
to log into his youtube and look at his
favorite videos go
oh
what does he become a pedophile susan
he comes a giant green pedophile
no no no no no no no no no and unlike
hulk the shorts are off shorts are off
they rip right off you won't like me in
fact that's his shirt's still on the
only the rips is the shorts yeah and he
still has long argyle socks
all of a sudden he grows like a werewolf
he grows pedophile glasses
it's a giant green
gene ripping boner he's just a giant
green stanley tucci from the lovely
bones just
be polite
that's the other rule
always be polite
so
let's look at some other
let's look at some other
rules here people understand black
people in this country also
statistically
get it's true sometimes different kinds
of sentencing let's look at what that
looks like uh
let's leave some examples first timothy
simpson shot three people in school
seventy five thousand dollar bill that's
the fort worth situation terrell josie
accused of shooting and killing a
detroit firefighter bail reduced from
one million to a hundred thousand
dollars george howard charged with
domestic violence released on a 1500
bond paid for by the minneapolis freedom
fund no word if by the way this has been
removed for gofundme kamala harris
contributed to that fund he was quickly
charged with two counts of secondary
murder after being released let's look
at the idea that cops are more likely to
shoot black men for no reason it's open
season because that's a justification
for the racist dog whistles that you
actually see from cnn cops are actually
18 and a half times more likely to be
shot by black men
than to shoot unarmed black men to be
clear we have the sources ref all
references available lot of credit.com
link in the description 18 and a half
times i got it wrong because i was going
by memory i think two weeks ago i said
16 times i undershot it 18 and a half
times keep in mind that there's a higher
percentage of police officers who are
black than the general percentage of the
population
so black men's lives are in danger 18
and a half times more likely to be in
danger
than even a black man committing a crime
what about the black officers
we've talked about them we've raised
money for them between 2010 2019 when
cops are feloniously killed it is look
303 were killed by whites 199 were
killed by blacks but take into account
that black americans only make up about
12 percent of the population
it's not even close
people need to understand that black men
shoot cops in record numbers right now
that is important it does go both ways
and by the way police officers are
actually 23 and a half percent less
likely to shoot black people than white
people people don't understand that
statistic they try and massage the
statistics and say well actually it's
unarmed black men versus why this is
when they say an unarmed black man is
more likely to be shot than an unarmed
white guy
this is a thought exercise
pick the part out of that that should
raise a question wait wait
why just unarmed
what about the total shootings
because you've now added a caveat that
by the way can't be quantified in just
that short statement because we also see
that black american males commit violent
assault and battery on officers at a
rate exponentially higher than white
people so unarmed well of course there's
going there going to be more discharges
of weapons when you look at the total
number of black people shot by police
officers versus white people
a white person is more likely to be shot
by a police officer
and just to be clear it shouldn't be
reliant on race just like mr coffey i am
thrilled that he has gotten off i hope
that this girl who shot her underage sex
her underage sex trafficking connoisseur
and killed him i hope that she gets off
and you know what maybe there will be
some justice for the [ __ ] you know
while i was busting moves in nevada from
this guy who plowed people down
at a parade who also engaged in pimping
miners but by the way what are we 10 20
so we're 11 26 this is monday 11 26
eastern and cnn has not told you that
it's let me read this again let me go
right back just really quickly for a
quick contrast so the man's name is
gerald you have this mr brooks jr oh so
they don't have any information at all
no yeah okay so it is 10 27 a.m eastern
by the way smash that like button if
you're watching on youtube and i want
you to comment as to how useless media
is
and whether mark ruffalo by the way
where
his fist oh that's his fist the like
button that's not that's the fist that
everyone wants to use edward norton if
you want he wants to
wear a gymboree so eric bana daryl
brooks jr it's 10 27 a.m uh sorry 11 27
a.m eastern darryl brooks jr
this is the man we just showed you the
police scanner tape okay
this is the man who ran people over he
was released on a one thousand dollar
bond two days ago for domestic abuse
bail jumping he's a registered sex
offender and he admitted in his own
words to pimpin hoes while he was
busting moves in nevada he has pro black
lives matter auntie kyle written house
posts anti-police posts we found this on
social media all of this we have given
to you his name description past
criminal history it is 10 27 central 11
27 central am on monday and what is cnn
giving you
he or she who may have committed the
crime there you go
i don't think you should ever trust our
institutions again youtube piss off
i